pour autant pour il est clair que pour
nous le rebond économique ne viendra pas
de las vegas je crois que plutôt que de
rêver de faire comme dans comme les
métropoles 1 et je pense en particulier
à ce que j'ai entendu en conseil d'agglo
à savoir qu'on allait faire de nevers
une nouvelle silicon valley il faut
s'appuyer sur nos atouts
le sens de l'histoire c'est des villes
écologiques c'est des villes humaines au
cadre de vie préservé
c'était une ville industrielle je vais y
venir juste après donc nous pensons
qu'il faut d'abord engager une
mobilisation générale pour la défense
des services publics et la défense de ce
qui existe des industries on a perdu 260
emplois à bach haydn industrie philippe
classe ennemis etc
dans le même temps malheureusement la
cub on n'affiche que trente emplois on a
toutes les missions on va avancer sur
cette idée de notre activité de la ville
amie des chameaux vous partager ce point
de vue tout à fait je rejoins
complètement le point de vue de nathalie
servi dans le sens où à mon avis le
premier mauvais choix c'est de choisir
de se rallier à la république en marche
qui ne leur est pas du tout dans le sens
de l'intérêt général pour la défense des
services publics dont les villes
moyennes comme la nôtre on entend le
besoin pour renforcer le soutien dont
ont besoin les écoles la santé et tous
les ai tous les services dont les
citoyens ont besoin dans ce rapport de
proximité et la plus ça va plus nous
nous éloignons de nos services publics
qui sont notre bien commun